former white house chief strategist
steve bannon is speaking out about
president trump's decision to end the
daca program
the obama-era policy protects nearly 800
000 immigrants from deportation they
came to this country illegally
as children we spoke to banner in an
interview for sunday's 60 minutes
it is his first extensive interview
since leaving the white house
look what he did on daca the other day
okay i don't agree with that daca
decision but i understand how he
struggled with it i understand how he's
giving a possibility of a legislative
thing and he said even last night in a
tweet
even a tweet he would rethink it trust
me the guys on the far right the guys on
the conservative side are not happy with
this
can i remind you a good catholic
the cardinal dolan
is opposed to what's happening with daca
cardinal
dolan the catholic church has been
terrible about this okay the bishops
have been terrible about this
by the way you know why you know why
because unable to really
to to to to to come to grips with the
problems in the church
they need illegal aliens they need
illegal aliens to fill the churches
that's uh it's obvious on the face of it
that's what that's what the entire
catholic bishop is condemning
they have an economic interest they have
an economic interest in unlimited
immigration unlimited illegal
immigration as much as
that's a tough thing to say about your
church as much as i respect
cardinal dolan and the bishops on
doctrine this is not doctrine
this is not doctrine at all i totally
respect
the pope and i totally respect the
catholic bishops and cardinals on
doctrine this is not about doctrine
this is about the sovereignty of a
nation and in that regard
they're just another guy with an opinion
we do want you to note that we reached
out to the archdiocese of new york this
morning
to see if they wanted to respond we're
waiting to hear back
really interesting to hear him to sort
of level that at the catholic church
number one to hear his voice a lot of
people
haven't heard that and he's never been
one of the first television interviewers
yeah
most people have not heard him speak
before but he certainly is not one to
mince words charlie i'm surprised he
came out
there's a lot more in this in terms of
how he wants to go to war against
republican leadership in the congress
and we will share how he views himself
and his plan to defend president trump
outside the white house
in the next hour half hour you can see
our full interview this
sunday evening at 7 6 central on 60
minutes
right here on cbs